los argentinos siguen sufriendo la
inflación en el mes de septiembre
alcanzó el 6,2% respecto al mes anterior
y el 83% Comparado con septiembre del
año pasado cada vez más argentinos
tienen que pensárselo dos veces antes de
hacer sus compras tenés que fijarte los
precios porque hay cosas que uno no
poder llevar Tenés que ir sacando cosas
de la Alimentación porque no te da el
suelto como para poder seguir hay gente
que la está pasando verdaderamente mal
Aunque Argentina vio bajar su tasa de
desempleo este año esto no pone a la
población a salvo de la precariedad ya
que los salarios no siguen el ritmo de
la inflación la pobreza afectada acerca
del 40% de los argentinos los precios
subieron un
76,1% en los nueve primeros meses del
año con los alimentos y El combustible
en primera línea minando los salarios y
los ahorros de los ciudadanos la gente
se nota que cada vez lleva menos te
regatea mucho los precios pie de precio
y lo que pasa que bueno un día vale
tanto el morrón otro le daba el doble
ahora vale 1400 pesos el kilo morrón o
sea lo que valía 600 500 la verdad se
está haciendo todo un poquito al demonio
en entrevista con Franz 24 el economista
Gustavo nefa analizó la situación no hay
un una solución a la vista más que
atarse a lo firmado con el fmi en
materia de gastos en materia de déficit
fiscal y sobre todo de la no remisión de
utilidades del Banco Central al tesoro
para cubrir gastos corrientes Argentina
es uno de los países más afectados por
el aumento de los precios de los
alimentos y de la energía desde la
invasión rusa en Ucrania que se junto
con la inflación estructural que sufre
el país desde hace años